President Trump said nothing yesterday
about George Floyd's funeral but he did
take the time to spread a right-wing
conspiracy theory on Twitter about a 75
year old protester who was shoved to the
ground by Buffalo police and severely
injured the president's claims have no
known basis in fact Ben Tracy reports
from the White House the video was
shocking 75 year old Martin Gugino
shoved to the ground by police in
Buffalo New York last week blood poured
out of his ear as officers walked by on
Tuesday with no evidence President Trump
said Gugino could be an NT foe
provocateur who was trying to scan
police communications to black out the
equipment and that falling to the ground
could be a setup it's common antifa
tactics that a president was spreading a
conspiracy theory started by far-right
media sources Gugino a well-known local
peace activist is still in the hospital
in a statement his attorney said we are
at a loss to understand why the
President of the United States would
make such dark dangerous in untrue
accusations against him what do you
think it was it was staged do you think
the blood coming out of his head was
staged is that what you're saying you
saw his head hit the pavement you see
blood on the pavement New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo demanded president Trump
apologize
I don't think Donald Trump's going to
change his behavior several Republicans
tried to avoid the topic including the
president's own chief of staff Marc
meadows
Meadows visited Capitol Hill on Tuesday
to discuss police reforms with
Republican senator Tim Scott a draft
report of Scott's plan obtained by CBS
News includes new reporting requirements
for deadly use of force incidents by
police increase funding for body cameras
and de-escalation training so far the
White House has not said what if any
rope reforms it would support meanwhile
President Trump is still considering
giving a national address about race and
unity but the White House is trying to
figure out where to do that we are told
it is unlikely to be an oval office
address Gale all right Ben thank you
very much we'd all be listening